so every once in a while you come across
something that just takes you completely
by surprise
i mean what exactly is going on here if
you think the camera has something to do
with it you're right today we're going
to look at a whole bunch of illusions
that mess with your visual perception
we're using a tone generator to run a
specific frequency in this case 24 hertz
which is 24 cycles per second through
that big speaker
when the speaker plays the tone it
vibrates at the same rate causing the
hose and the water flowing through it to
undulate at the same frequency
to the naked eye it looks like it's
spraying everywhere and it is
but it's not spraying randomly if we set
our camera to match the rate at which
the water is moving then we get this
here's what it looks like to the naked
eye
and here's what happens when we adjust
the camera's frame rate
and if you manipulate the frequency
deliberately you can produce even more
effects